my biggest regret in business was not
starting sooner it took me four years to
build my first website and the day I
actually started to build my first
website it took me 10 hours and so the
thing is it takes usually about 20 hours
to become proficient at any skill we do
but most of us myself included wait
years to take the first hour and it's
not that we avoid learning new skills
because we're lazy we avoid learning new
skills because we're afraid of sucking
and we're afraid of failing and feeling
insufficient the more I try and train
myself out of that and Associate the
feeling of insufficiency with the
feeling of learning and growth the
faster I've been able to compress the
years between when I want to start doing
something when I actually start so that
when I want to start doing something I
actually start immediately so I can
start paying down those first 10 or 20
or 30 hours of learning how to do it in
the beginning